(somber piano music)
- This is the second worst
day here at IU North.
(somber music)
Yesterday, got a Doctor
Bannec, B-A-N-N-E-C,
wanted to send me home.
"You're not even short of breath."
I said, "Yes, I am."
(somber music)
I was in so much pain from my neck.
My neck hurt so bad.
(somber music)
I was crushed.
It made me feel like I was a drug addict.
(somber music)
The CT went down a
little bit into my lungs
and you could see new
pulmonary infiltrates,
new lymphadenopathy
all throughout my neck.
And all of a sudden, "Yes,
we'll treat your pain."
You have to show proof
that you have something wrong with you.
I put forward and I maintained.
If I was white, I wouldn't
have to go through that.
(somber music)
This is how black people get
killed, when you send them home
and they don't know how
to fight for themselves.
I had to talk to somebody,
maybe the media, somebody
to let people know how I'm
being treated up in this place.
(dramatic music)
- Today we're gonna be
having a very important
yet difficult conversation
about racism within healthcare,
social disparities within
the healthcare system
and to see what actionable
things we can do to fight back.
I'd like to send our condolences
to Dr. Moore's family
and a commitment that
I'm gonna make a donation
on their GoFundMe page.
I'm linking that down below as well,
if you'd like to contribute to.
In order to have this in-depth discussion,
I've invited special
guests, Dr. Kadijah Ray,
a pediatric anesthesiologist
and founder of the group,
Physician Women SOAR.
Let's get right into it.
The difficult part of
having this conversation
after the fact, is that because
of patient privacy rules,
the institution cannot
really adequately say
what was happening, what the results were.
We can only go by the
information that was released
by Dr. Moore herself.
My question to you is based on her videos
and her writings on Facebook,
how did the topic of racism
enter the conversation
and how should we be thinking about it
when we're considering her own situation?
- Yeah, I think after a
certain amount of time
of this treatment and this denial
of how serious her symptoms
were as she perceived them,
and as we perceived them, being told,
"Well, you're really not short of breath."
I mean, anybody watching
that video, you don't have
to have a medical degree to appreciate
that she could barely
finish her sentences.
One thing that we try to
explain to people in the work
that I do is that we know
what racism looks like.
Just like a woman knows
what sexism looks like.
There are things and people,
the way people interact,
certain things that are
said, microaggressions,
macro aggressions, where,
you know what it looks like.
And that's what she felt was happening.
And she put that name to it.
She felt that it became,
or it was racially driven.
And maybe the doctor didn't even realize
that was driving him.
And we can talk about that
more later, but there was,
you know, after a point
of being mistreated
and mishandled, she
felt that it was racism.
- And I've seen your response,
but with the Physician Women's SOAR group
to the response that the organization gave
as to what they thought was
a breakdown in communication.
And one of the main things you pointed out
was that they did not even
address the word racism
in their response.
Ideally, how would you
have had that conversation
say you were in the position of authority
overseeing this incident?
How would you have used the word racism?
What would have been the
ideal approach there?
- Well, I mean, I understand
that when you're in the shoes
of a big organization, I'm
sure they had their PR people
and their lawyers and everybody else
kinda help craft that statement.
But if I was in a position
where I'm making a statement
and I want to have an honest conversation,
you have to be transparent
and you have to not take away
what a person is saying.
You have to listen to
what the person is saying.
We can't, as institutions,
make pledges to do better,
to do better regarding social
justice, racial justice
and then not listen when you're being told
that you missed the mark.
And I would just say exactly that.
Dr. Susan Moore did not receive the care
that she felt she should have received.
She said that it was due to racism,
and we are going to do everything we can
to investigate this particular situation
and to educate our team and our staff
so that we can do better by
the community that we serve.
We all have implicit biases.
And unfortunately, sometimes
those implicit biases
cause issues in the work
that we have been charged
with doing.
- To me, I see huge
inequalities that happen
with communities of color.
Access to medications
whether it's financial
or physical, distance wise.
When I recommend a
healthy diet to a patient,
do they actually have the
ability to acquire that diet?
Do they live in a food desert?
Like the fact that zip codes
are oftentimes more predictive
of someone's health than
their actual lab values.
All of these things are partial factors
that doctors who think
holistically should be thinking
about their patients.
How do we distinguish
systemic inequalities
that a lot of times were
created because of racism
in our past, how do we distinguish
between issues like that
and situations like Dr. Moore's
where racism seems to be
a direct sort of claim
against the people delivering the care?
How do we balance those two?
- I think it's really, it's
hard to balance the two.
But we just have to be
honest with ourselves.
There's a Harvard implicit bias test
that I think every everybody should take.
Most people are just shocked (giggles)
at really what it tells
them about themselves.
And I think that once we
start having a hard look
at ourselves, doing an
active work to undo some
of these things, then everything
kinda, will work together.
The systemic issues versus
the individual issues.
But we need to start with
ourselves individually.
And then the institutions
need to make real commitments
not just writing a pledge
when something is popular
in the media, who are you
hiring to do this work?
Who's monitoring this information?
And where do you start?
I would almost maintain
that, once you started having
these conversations with
doctors who are already working,
who've been in the field
for 20 years, 25 years,
who were at the hospital,
it's a little late.
I mean, I guess it's never too late,
but we need to start much
earlier in medical school,
having these conversations, these classes,
and really unpacking this information.
- In a court of law,
you're judging an action.
Whether or not someone stole
a car or didn't steal a car.
When you're talking about racism,
you're talking about partially intent.
And that requires a lot of difficulty
'cause unless they outwardly say something
or write something, it's
almost impossible to prove.
So while that is the case, I
think people take advantage
of that fact that they say,
"Oh, you can't prove I was being racist."
Well, if someone with lived experience
who understands the microaggressions,
the tropes as well as you do,
we should trust that person
to be able to make that distinction.
And even if it doesn't mean that it's a,
a judicial ruling, it
could mean as something
as trusting an individual to
make the right call, right?
- Correct.
Correct.
- Yeah.
- There has to be some
kind of accountability.
We address that in the Medium article
where the hospital systems
across Indiana made a pledge
to better serve the communities
and to start addressing on
racial justice within medicine.
People have to start holding
each other accountable,
one institution to the
other and, you know,
help each other out.
We need to have these conversations
and really get to the bottom
of what drives us and
drives our decision-making
and acknowledge that there's a lot of data
and literature there.
Open up the New England
Journal of Medicine
and find so many studies
documented of pain control
not being the same amongst black.
Black infants having the
highest mortality in the NICU,
black women not surviving breast cancer
at the same rate as white women.
That's not because of
their genetic makeup.
It's because of later diagnosis,
not having the same
treatment options offered.
And by the time these things
are caught, it's too late.
The same with black men
and prostate cancer.
The data is there.
It's not being made up.
So if that's there and we know it,
then we have to start asking
the question of the why,
how is this happening?
Why are people of color not receiving
the same types of physical
exams as their counter parts?
Why is that happening?
And then try to do something about it
instead of then when we get the result
that goes into this data
and literature saying,
"Well, but how do we know?"
I mean, it's there, it's right there.
- Yeah.
- And we just have to acknowledge it
in order to do something about it.
- Yeah, these disparities existing,
should not necessarily lead us to say,
"Well, the whole system is racist."
At least I don't think it
should be labeled this way.
You can disagree with me or agree with me.
I'm curious actually
but perhaps to say
these disparities exist,
we need to figure out why.
And if it's because of past
racist medical research,
past racist based systemic
inequalities of housing,
of red lining, that inherently
makes the systemic inequality
happen as a result of racism,
not necessarily the fact
that the individuals involved
in that current system
are racist themselves.
- You have the systemic and
the institutionalized racism
where you have people
who don't have a quality
of living, you know, they
don't have the food available.
And they're living in places
where there's chemical racism
as far as the environment,
there's a lot of people doing
some great work in that field.
And then you have the doctor
who may be from some small town,
who's never seen a black person,
and now they're not
doing that physical exam
the way they should
and they miss that this
woman has breast cancer.
- I love that with this channel,
that we can perhaps put some pressure
on some of these institutions.
How would you go about encouraging them,
as a nice word, of making a
change for both black patients,
black communities, minority communities
but also their physicians
and other healthcare workers?
- We have to put value on lives.
We can't say that this one
life that's in this suburb
is more valuable than the life that's here
in this inner city.
And without resources,
then you're not gonna
have good doctors who are
gonna wanna go work there.
Because like you said,
they're gonna get burned out.
They're not gonna last,
they're gonna leave.
But until these institutions
make a real commitment and say,
"These communities are just
as valuable as the next.
And we have to find
ways to put the money in
so that we have the
resources so that our doctors
and our staff are supported
so they can do the jobs
that they need to do,"
it's a really tough hill to climb.
And then once you get past that,
then what are we going to do internally
to assure that we have the skills?
And I don't mean just the medical skills,
but all the skills that we
need to be able to communicate,
educate, interact, and serve the community
in which we're choosing to be in
in whatever institution that is.
- You've mentioned also
some great practical points
for providers, as far as
knowing your obligation,
being introspective, going
past the science and thinking
about lived experiences
and communication factors.
Anything, if anything, do
you think that you would say
to patients, perhaps minority
patients who feel like,
that they would like to do
something to improve the quality
of their care?
Is there anything you
counsel your patients on?
- Well, you know, it's interesting
because this question it's come up a lot.
I am, I did a radio show
for a show in Minnesota
where people were asking
like, "Wait a minute,
if this doctor couldn't
advocate for herself,
then how are we supposed to
when we don't speak the language,
we don't have the
knowledge or the resources?
But what I can, what I
try to tell people is to
do your best to advocate for yourself.
If a doctor is speaking to you
and you don't understand
what they're saying,
you know, what tests they're ordering,
why they're telling you, you
need to take a medication,
ask them to explain it
again until you understand.
If you feel like you are being mistreated,
then if it's an option
to seek another opinion
or to switch doctors, then do so.
If you feel like you're
not getting the care
and the treatment that you deserve,
then know that you can
get a patient advocate
within the hospital to
come and be by your side,
to try to help you navigate the system.
And then I would tell people, if you feel
like you're not getting what you need,
then maybe try to find a doctor
that you can better relate to.
If you are a man and you
feel more comfortable
with a male physician,
then maybe seek that out
so that you're able to better communicate
and openly discuss your medical concerns
so that you can get the
care that you deserve.
- And this isn't an
obligation for patients.
It's our obligation to make sure
that the patient understands.
When you're listening
to a patient's reaction
to your instructions, is
the same when a doctor
is performing a speculum exam
should be making eye contact
with the patient as well to
make sure they're comfortable.
So it's the doctor's obligation
and the institution's obligation
to make sure the patient's
getting good care.
The reason we're giving these extra bits
or you're giving these tidbits to patients
is to go the extra mile.
And it's not their
responsibility to do this.
We have to constantly
remind providers that
because they say,
"Well, then why didn't the
patient advocate for themselves?"
Well, while they can,
and that oftentimes fails
as seen in Dr. Moore's case.
It's just something that I
would tell my family member
almost to expect the medical
system at times to fail.
And if they're able to advocate
and educate themselves,
they will statistically
have better outcomes.
And perhaps that will not
solve all our problems
but it can at least give
some practical advice
for those who are
interested in seeking it.
How do we go about talking
of, about racism historically
and present, without further deteriorating
the doctor patient
relationship that exists
between the black community,
as an example, and doctors?
- We can't put that acknowledgement
potentially causing a
problem back on the community
that has been wronged.
So the-
- For sure.
- The talking about it
and the conversations,
the acknowledgement is not the issue
or the problem of the
black community, okay?
So we have to, 'cause we know.
There's a wonderful book
called "Medical Apartheid"
that talks about how these,
while the medical establishment
has not documented
a lot of the abuses, these situations,
these experiences have been passed down
amongst our communities even
verbally for hundreds of years.
So it's well known.
So what do we do, for example,
when we are now faced
with the COVID vaccine
and how do we get communities
to then say, "Okay, well,
I'm gonna go get this vaccine,"
when there's this long
historical relationship
where we haven't been treated that well,
we've been tricked many times.
It comes into education, having
people who look like them,
who they trust, providing that information
and being available to answer questions
which is a whole other conversation
about how we are
underrepresented in medicine
and in medical school and why?
That's a whole other conversation.
But there are plenty of
studies that have been done
that show that black patients do better
with doctors who look like them.
Instead of saying that
those communities don't trust
the medical establishment,
we have to change our
speech, which then starts
to change the way we think.
The medical establishment has
not done what they need to do
to earn the trust of those communities.
- So, if I'm hearing you
right, just to reiterate,
in order for us to do better
in the medical space
to treat our patients,
because ultimately as a whole,
we wanna help everybody.
That's the goal, the oath
that we take as physicians,
as nurses, we need to do better
in reaching out to communities,
creating more diversity
within our own groups
so that they can communicate
better and take this long road
to improving our ability to communicate
with the black community for example.
- Yes, that's correct.
For example, you know, you
have primary care doctors
who say, "Oh my goodness,
it's just so frustrating.
Mrs. so-and-so just won't take
the blood pressure medicine,"
or, "won't take their diabetic
medications," or, you know,
"they're just not
compliant, just don't..."
You have to have a conversation,
a real human conversation,
and this can apply to any patient really.
The why, why is that?
Is it access?
Is it financial?
Is it some kind of belief system
where they're afraid
to take the medication?
If you really have an honest
conversation with yourself
as a physician, did you
stop and really explain
and assured that they
understood the importance
of whatever it is, whatever
treatment, tests, whatever it is
that you're trying to communicate?
Did you communicate in a
way that they understand?
Did you read the body language to see
was there some kind of
trepidation on the part
of the patient and really
get to the bottom of why?
- A good friend and colleague
of mine, Dr. Judy Washington
actually works with the STFM organization
to increase diversity in medicine,
to have this conversation.
They actually have an
underrepresented minority fund
to help with scholarships.
Is this the sole solution
or do we need to think past
scholarships, past admissions?
Is there something we're missing here
that we haven't yet tried?
- Oh boy, Dr. Mike, that's
a whole other segment.
(Dr. Kadijah laughing)
Yeah, I mean, it does go
past the scholarships.
By that time, it's almost too late.
We have to start by figuring out
what's going on in the
public school system?
What's going on in the inner cities?
What's happening with the STEM programs
in those schools and those children,
when they're in elementary school?
They don't have the resources.
And I think COVID has exposed
a lot of those disparities.
People don't even have computers
or access to wifi and the internet.
So how could they possibly, you know,
get involved in and do
what they need to do
for some of these classes and programs?
You know, there are issues
at the primary school level,
the inner city schools and we
are missing potential doctors
because they're just not being fostered.
They're going to high schools
that don't have a strong AP program.
If you don't have AP
classes or honors classes
then how are you gonna get
into a competitive college?
So it goes back to that
institutionalized racism
that nobody likes to discuss,
but it's certainly there
where there are children
all over this country
who don't have the same
opportunities and while their minds
and their capabilities
are just like others,
there's nothing there to foster it.
They don't have the programming.
And so they don't have those
opportunities to even go
to a college that would
be competitive enough
to prepare them.
I grew up in the inner
city, South side of Chicago.
And there is a program that's been around
for a very long time
since the seventies called the CAHMCP,
Chicago Area Health and
Medical Careers Program.
And it was a housed over at the IIT.
There was a college, IIT on
the South side of Chicago
and that was what their
program was all about.
Taking young children who
had some kind of propensity
or interest in science and
math and following them
all the way through
high school, all the way
to medical school and
without a program like that,
coming from the inner city,
I don't think I would be
sitting here with you today.
- That's such a sad point to hear,
but an important point to hear
that young folks are trapped
in this vicious cycle
that either they're not exposed
to good education early on
or even if they have interests early on,
their communities are not set up
to foster that sort of enthusiasm
or they get pulled into
crime ridden communities.
And as a result, they lose
focus on their education
or it's not a knock at all
on STFM and the scholarships
and the amazing work that they're doing.
It's just showing that,
while that is part of what we need to do,
there's this whole other
under-addressed section
of the beginning,
of how we get students to
get these scholarships.
And the reality of the fact,
when we look at a lot of
the assistance programs
that we have, even in my
hospital where I work,
a lot of them go unclaimed.
And it's partially because
our lack of communication,
it's because failed communication.
And because we're not
addressing that initial stage
that you talked about,
of starting people up
to know that these programs
exist, to get them excited
about becoming a pediatric
anesthesiologists like yourself.
And that initial start is
such an important place
to talk about and focus on
that I really hope as we move forward
in the era of investing into
healthcare, into children,
we really think about
that educational aspect.
And I hope that's where
a lot of change happens.
I'm one of those perhaps naive believers
that if with education, you
could change almost everything.
If you have an educated patient,
in that, it won't solve every problem,
it'll improve their outcomes.
If you have education to young folks
they'll be excited to be providers
and then be providers for the people
who perhaps look more like
them and have better outcomes.
So I really would like to see
more incentivization early on
as opposed to going to high
school solely and saying,
"Well, if you go, we can
give you this scholarship,"
that early on aspect is something
I'm really passionate about as well.
- Yeah, I think, I
mean, I think it's great
those scholarships and the scholarships
like the one that your friend is doing
is important and again,
all things like that
is what allowed me to
get through the system
and many of my friends.
So it's all very important.
We just have to continue to look
at every level because we're missing out
on a lot of people who could do very well
but they're just not given the opportunity
and they don't have that access.
- I know we covered a lot.
I'd love to leave you with the last word.
What do you think should
be the ultimate message
to the million plus people
hopefully that will watch this video?
- I think that I would just
like to impart on people
that the discussion about race
is a very difficult discussion
but it's one that's necessary.
People are dying and people
are dying needlessly so
because of, just because
of the color of their skin
and that's unacceptable.
We have to reach out to our neighbors
and try to understand each
other, have conversations,
get to know each other
and don't deny other people's experiences.
My condolences go out to
Dr. Susan Moore's family.
We lost a big part of
our medical community.
And I think that we should
all walk away from that.
Just remembering that when somebody,
when a black person or a person of color
or whatever the situation
is, when somebody speaks
and they're saying
something, we have to listen.
She knows what, she knew what racism was.
She called it, and it may have
possibly cost her her life.
I say that Dr. Moore passed
away due to two things,
two pandemics, the
pandemic, the COVID pandemic
and the racism pandemic.
We have to have these conversations
so that we can take that off of the table.
People need to be treated fairly.
We know what our experiences are
and just because you
have not experienced it,
you have to approach these conversations
with an open heart and ear
and have some empathy so that
we can get some real change.
- Thank you so much, Dr. Ray.
I'm linking all of your
information down below
where people can find you,
your Physician SOAR group
and to continue their education
much like I need to do
in reading "Medical
Apartheid", other resources
to continue learning,
'cause we're all imperfect.
We all have implicit biases.
And I thank everybody for watching
and Dr. Ray for her wise words and advice.
(upbeat music)